today so she asked me to introduce our
speaker
um and I see that we have a number of
um folks from outside the department
which is great
um so I'll maybe I'll give my usual
spiel about the um a master's thesis
defense which is what is happening today
um Angie McGraw is our speaker she will
be
um defending her thesis I assume her
committee is here
um she'll give a Public Presentation
we'll take any questions from the public
and then
um the public will be dismissed and her
committee may have further questions for
her and then she'll be dismissed and the
committee will decide
um so just a few
um comments about Angie who's probably
known to most of you
um she is
um
um about to complete pending this
defense
um her uh master of science in the
bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine major and
um she actually
um is already in a job she is currently
in the NIH post-baccalaureate intra
mural research training award program in
the lab of Dr Nan ping Peter Wang who I
see here
um before coming to OHSU um Angie
received the Bachelor of Science and
computer science from Portland State and
so I will turn it over to her
thank you so much for the introduction
my name is Andrew McGraw and the title
of my thesis is an evaluation of best
practices for Clinical Laboratory
Improvement amendments bioinformatics
Pipelines
as for a little bit of a premise given
the rapid advances in technology and
computational complexity there may be
gaps in best practices and guidelines to
support the current challenges facing
clear Laboratories
for a study overview Next Generation
sequencing technologies have provided
opportunities for personalized
treatments whole genome sequencing which
is an NGS technology allows for the
exponential generation of data we
highlight the potential of NGS based
informatics pipelines and precision
breast oncology treatments and the need
for standardization
broadly speaking we need set guidelines
and standards to ensure pipeline
accuracy appropriateness and efficacy as
well as those protectational safety and
ensure quality patient care
our study has two aims the first was to
conduct a literature review to assess
current best practices for Clear
bioinformatics pipelines and to identify
potential gaps
our second aim the use case for our
second aim is to determine reference
background distributions for expression
signatures for clinical usage
so now we're going to be diving into aim
one
all right so LAX Laboratories this was a
headline newspaper article in the Wall
Street Journal and up until this point
so we're thinking about late 1900s up
until this point Laboratories had been
largely unregulated
and this illustrates one example of that
in which people were getting incorrect
results with cancer screening and so
essentially people were being told that
they had cancer when they didn't have
cancer and this is an indication of a
false positive and this whole situation
indicated why there needed to be more
guidance and regulations when it comes
for to clinical laboratories
so in response to concerns regarding
Clinical Laboratory Testing flia was
established in 1988. they stated that
certifications certifies that the
laboratory has developed a validated
clinical say that is reproducible
precise and accurate which established
sensitivity and specificity
they also state that Laboratories must
maintain data management systems entail
accurate record-keeping and Implement
standards for bioinformatics Pipelines
so this timeline is not an exhaustive
timeline but it indicates how Laboratory
Testing has evolved over time
so starting off from the left hand side
we're looking at 1993 and earlier so
these were your Eliza or antigen-based
tests so these were simpler tests and so
moving on like moving on from 1993 we
saw that Laboratory Testing has evolved
to include omic space tests and what
omics basically means is that when you
have sequencing data that falls under
the development omics and with omics you
have bioinformatics because you need way
to process the sequencing data so what
this essentially means is that
bioinformatics is going to be here to
stay because we're constantly generating
sequencing data and so in 2006 there was
draft guidance on ivd Mias and these
were in vitro diagnostic multivariate
index assays and so this was the very
first time where we had clinical data an
algorithm and a threshold to interpret
the results
so the first IBD miasa that was approved
was member print and so mammaprint was a
70g microarray based test and what
membrint does is that it predicts
whether breast cancer is likely to
return within five to ten years
and since then since the approval of
this essay there's been more ngs-based
mutation and Gene signatures as well as
other new tests and so now we're really
getting into this idea of clinical
genomics
so clinical genomics has become really
pervasive especially in the recent years
and so for the sake of time we're going
to be focused on the right hand side of
this diagram but what this diagram
essentially shows is that overall
clinical genomics is a dynamic process
because annotations are constantly being
updated and so for the right hand side a
common use case for clinical genomics is
genetic screening and with genetic
screening we're looking at NGS which
again is next Generation sequencing so
we're looking at either a whole exome
sequencing whole genome sequencing or
targeted array and so the pipelines are
now going to be focused on alignment
bearing calling and filtering as well as
classification and so to dive further
into clinical genomics we conducted a
literature review so in this literature
review in this top panel so if this top
graph right here we're going to be
looking at clinical bioinformatics and
clinical genomics and in this we see
that clinical genomics gives us a
greater span than clinical
bioinformatics but then when we looked
at this bottom panel here we looked at
Medical genetics and we saw that medical
genetics provided a larger and more
relevant Corpus for a review and so it's
important to note that these y-axis
aren't to the same scale the top panel
caps out around 2000 and then the bottom
panel caps out around 20 000 which means
that medical genetics has become more
prevalent in research we also found
through our literature review that
there's High variability in applications
when it comes to medical genetics so for
instance in clinical usage potential
clinical usage in CLIA and so on
so continuing with our timeline so this
is 2012. this is just five years from
when that first will say that
incorporated clinical data and algorithm
and threshold that was just five years
from one this will say it was approved
so just five years from this there was
scientific fraud and falsification that
occurred so there was an Institute of
medicine report on translational omics
and so this report came about because
there was scientific fraud and
falsification that resulted in incorrect
gene expression based signatures used in
clinical cancer trials and on patients
so the researchers claimed that they've
achieved a genomic technology that could
predict with up to 90 accuracy which
early stage lung cancer patients were
likely to have a recurrence and would
therefore benefit from chemotherapy
and so the data that they were using was
falsified and so they were intentionally
misassigning the patients as to like
whether or not they would benefit from
chemotherapy or not and so this report
from The Institute of medicine focused
on how to prevent this from happening
again
so this report was followed up in 2013
By more guidelines from the national
counseling Institute with omic space
test development scientists
and so these guidelines apply to any
clinical trial involving the use of an
omics test which is a sequencing test
that would involve the clinical
management of patients in a given trial
and so that means like any tests that
involve the selection of therapy for a
patient and so there were a number of
recommendations but this slide just
highlights those on model development
and many of these recommendations were
involving increased rigor and how
algorithms sorry and how algorithms and
methods needed to be more appropriate
in 2014 so a year after we had a
technology review that highlighted the
rapid shift towards clinical sequencing
and when we're reading this figure each
of these rows or each of these bars
indicates a company so 29 would mean
that there's 29 companies in this topic
or this category of consumables and
arrays and so for all purposes we're
going to be focused on this red box
right here and the spread box includes
alignment and annotation interpretation
and recording and data storage and
bundling so what this figure essentially
shows is that companies were providing
arrays and sequencing but then they move
towards providing bioinformatic support
So a way to process the sequencing that
they're generating
and so I'd now like to highlight two
case studies that involve binformatics
workflows so this first case study
highlights how to address the issue of
reducing bigger and sorry increasing
rigor and reducing error in pipelines so
this first case study is titled the use
of semantic workflows to enhance
transparency and reproducibility and
clinical omics
so semantic workflows in simple terms
this is where users are guided through
each workflow run so there's going to be
guidelines for the user to follow as
well as interpretations of the workflow
and so this type of workflow semantic
workflows enhance analytical validity
and patient safety
so in this study they stated that
workbook platforms such as Galaxy and
Taverna have increased the use
transparency and reproducibility of
omics analysis Pipelines
they also state that domain knowledge
creates challenges when attempting to
transfer a pipeline from research to
clinical settings
as a basic study overview they analyze
the effectiveness of semantic workflows
and the workflows that they analyzed was
called Wings they also implemented a
clinical omics pipeline to annotate DNA
sequence variants identified through NGS
Technologies
so one of the key findings was that
implementation of a clinical omics
pipeline through semantic workflow
allowed for the pipeline to meet the
clinical omic standards for transparency
reproducibility and analytical validity
the system that they analyze addresses
four needs in clinical omics analyzes
one being frequent updates to multiple
life science databases Sciences
constantly being done which means that
these databases are frequently being
updated
two being that heterogeneity and
consistency of biological data three
being rapid development of omic software
tools so with this exponential
generation of data people are going to
try to be able to tackle this data so
that's why the development process is
going to be rapid and then for
processing of large omics data sets
they also included a checklist for
pipeline development so they said that
pipeline development they should include
exact input data used for the analysis
key intermediate data generated from the
analysis third-party data and then all
code and software used in the analysis
and these four checklist points indicate
that transparency and reach the
producibility contributes to increasing
rigor and reducing errors in Pipelines
the second case study is a study
examining an implemented pipeline for
our pathogen identification and this is
a public health study
so the study is called a cloud
compatible bioinformatics pipeline for
Ultra rapid pathogen identification from
Next Generation sequencing of clinical
samples
so they stated that NGS technologies
have allowed for development of
computational approaches to maintain
public health so there's high
applicability with bonformatics
pipelines but there's difficulties to
transition from a research setting to
clinical trials because of integration
accuracy and time efficiency
as a basic study overview they utilize
metagenomic data from 237 clinical
samples and from this they constructed a
cloud compatible binformatics pipeline
called serpi for comprehensive pathogen
identification
they identified three main challenges
with developing bioinformatics pipelines
one being that alignment and
classification algorithms must contend
with massive amounts of sequence data
two being that only a small fraction of
short NGS reads and clinical metagenomic
data corresponds to the pathogens and
three being that novel microorganisms
with Divergent genomes are not well
represented in existing reference
databases
they also assess service feasibility in
real-time clinical analysis so they
utilize acute serum sample from a 20
year old female with a three-day fever
my ugliest and a headache this patient
was exposed to a region of Australia
that had mosquito-borne Alpha viruses
and within 13 minutes sequences that
span the hhv-7 virus were detected and
so the fact Illustrated here is that you
could have a very high false negative
rate where only a small amount of
sequences or actual variants and so a
big challenge in this use case is that
false negatives are a huge issue and so
the prior use case that we went to
basically is the challenge of how to
reduce air whereas this challenge faces
this case study faces the challenge of
reducing false negatives and so as a
takeaway from this case study the
pipeline that they analyzed was both
accurate and efficient and was able to
produce results in the desired time
frame
so now moving forward with our timeline
we're in 2018 now this is where we had
joint recommendations from the
association for molecular pathology and
the College of American pathologists
they stated that because there's a lack
of published guidance there's currently
a high degree of variability and how
members of the global molecular genetics
and pathology Community establish and
validate bioinformatics pipelines so
before CLIA came in to provide
guidelines but tests as you can imagine
over time become more complex and more
variable and people assumed that Cleo
would cover every aspect of pylon
development but since tests became so
variable and so complex so rapidly these
guidelines don't cover every aspect of
the bioinformatics pipeline development
process
and so these joint recommendations
involve 17 best practices and the key
themes were training and validation and
we want to place an emphasis that when
it comes to training training isn't
going to be a shortcomer a shortcoming
of the trainer or the learner but rather
more training alone isn't going to solve
the problems we're going to need to
think about what needs to be included in
the training and we need to make sure
that the training is obligated
so we updated our literature review to
being since 2018. so 2018 was when we
had the joint recommendations so then we
carried out a literature review from
2018 and onwards and the three key terms
that we were focused on were validation
bioinformatics and clinical and as you
can see over the years we've seen an
increase in these three terms in
literature indicating their importance
in literature their increasing
importance in literature
and so from the literature review we saw
that there are still challenges in
validation and currently with existing
methods they involve case studies and
use case reports and then in some
instances Publications can be used as a
surrogate for actual validation meaning
some Publications that are producing a
pipeline will be using other
Publications to validate their data
instead of having a having parameters
and models to test their pipelines and
then moving to this middle box here
there's also no pre-existing methods or
workflows so there's no Baseline
comparison point for the Pipelines in
addition level validation for algorithms
vary and there's also a lack of gold
standard and appropriate references
and then in terms of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
there's a lack of explainability and
interpretability and especially for deep
learning there's also training versus
operational site differences and then
we're also seeing distributional drifts
so adrift in the data which can also
impact the outcome of the model
so the lack of a gold standard and a
reference was the area that we had the
opportunity to investigate in aim to
so aim2 our use case for this was to
determine background distributions for
expression signatures for clinical usage
so starting off one of the key things
here is to understand what a ideal
reference or null distribution is so the
goal here is to have an appropriate
reference distribution so a baseline
comparison point so this distribution
would give us appropriateness to assess
outliers due to real treatment effects
so thinking back to basic statistics we
have a normal distribution curve on the
screen and so this normal distribution
curve at the extreme tails the ends of
this this would be a patient's sample
indicating actual treatment effect
so we stated we had four key
characteristics for an optimal reference
or null distribution one being that
expressions and samples are appropriate
for the disease type so our reference
distribution should consist of Gene
Expressions that are appropriate for the
given disease that we're looking at
two being that there's biological
variability sample to sample but is it
due to technical artifacts so there's
obviously going to be differences in
gene Expressions but this should be due
because of the differences in samples
and not due to differences in batches
thirdly there should be a large enough
distribution to avoid sampling error so
the genes that we're looking at there
should be enough relevant genes for us
to avoid sampling error
and fourth pairwise differences among
samples should reflect normal biological
variability but be less than the actual
treatment effects at present and this
would allow us to identify real changes
on therapy
so the measure that we were looking at
or the samples that we're looking at for
our distribution for our null reference
distribution our uhr replicates and so
uhr replicates essentially their irna
isolated from a diverse set of 10 cancer
cell lines and what a cancer cell line
is is that they're cancer cells that are
that keep dividing and growing over time
and normally they're in a lab condition
and so these are a collection of cells
originating from one cells so the pros
of using uhr replicates for a reference
distribution is that their Universal
reference they're also again a mixture
of cancer cell lines and from literature
we know that they provide background
distributions to assess significant pre
and post treatment changes
the cons of using uh about the kits is
that even though they're a mixture of
cancer cell lines they're not going to
be exhausted for all cell cancer types
they're also lab cold samples and not
actual patient samples and our use case
for this was looking at deltas and
ranked Deltas so both of them measure
differences in gene expressions for
patients pre and on treatment
so as a little bit of background on
breast cancer which is the disease that
we're going to be looking at for
analyzes is that breast cancer is the
leading cause of cancer-related deaths
among women in the United States
breast tumors develop into benign tumors
or metastatic carcinomas through
constant stimulation and currently the
five-year survival rate is above 80
percent due to early prevention
and there's approximately 2.2 million
newly diagnosed cases and over half a
million death cases that were recorded
in 2020 so breast cancer is currently
curable for approximately 70 to 80
percent of patients with the early
non-metastatic stage of breast cancer
but when we move to more invasive
cancers that's where treatment becomes
more difficult
so now looking at current breast cancer
therapy so we have non-metastatic cancer
so this is where cancer is localized to
the origin point and then we have
metastatic cancer where cancer is spread
from the origin point to other organs so
the more invasive cancer
so for non-metastatic cancer the goal of
the therapy is to eradicate the tumor
from the breast and Regional lymph nodes
and and to also prevent metastatic
occurrence current therapies involve
surgical resection sampling or removal
of axillary lymph nodes and
post-operative radiation for metastatic
cancer
this is treatment based based upon
metastatic cancer subtypes the goal of
this type of cancer the goal of this
therapy is prolong the patient's life
and to provide relief to the patient
and for therapies for metastatic cancer
we're going to be targeting multiple
cells or tissues with receptors for a
particular drug
so now we're moving towards Precision
oncology and precision oncology follows
the idea that since each patient is
unique their cancer is going to be
unique and precision oncology utilizes a
patient's molecular and biological
features to optimize therapy and drugs
that Target oncogenic mechanisms
and as outlined by a recent study many
treatments have been designed for
patients with the same disease but the
following might be observed one symptoms
of disease may be reduced and this is
what we want two and three expected
responses may fail to occur and side
effects may arise which is what we don't
want and so now with Precision oncology
we're going to be moving towards
studying gene expression and specific
organs tissues or tumors so then that
means we're going to be looking at
understanding the differences in gene
expression between patients and then pre
and on therapy
so the Hallmarks of cancer these are
essential to cancer biology so homoster
cancer are going to be essentially six
traits that Define cancers so the first
one is sustaining proliferative
signaling the second one is evading
growth suppressors third one is
activating Invasion and metastasis
fourth is enabling replicative
immortality fifth is inducing
angiogenesis and six is reducing cell
resisting cell death so the purpose of
the Hallmarks is the purpose of using
the harmrex is to see if certain
Hallmarks are unregulated in a given
patient and then this is important
because there are 50 Gene sets that
represent the Hallmarks but the
Hallmarks are comprised of six traits
so for our purposes we're looking at 27
of the 50 Gene sets and these 27 Gene
sets were prioritized by the diagnostic
laboratories and there's 27 of them but
I'll just list out a couple one of them
is estrogen response early and then
another is make targets version one
so there's been an increasing interest
in the application of the Hallmarks so
the study on the left in 2018 was titled
the diverse genomic landscape of
clinically low-risk prostate cancer so
they observed tumor biology and gene
expression patterns among men with
clinically low-risk prostate cancer and
they utilize Hallmark Gene sets such as
mic targets due to them checkpoints and
e2f targets and in this study they
determined average genomic risk scores
from the Hallmark Gene sets and they
found that risk scores were associated
with worse pathology findings and they
were associated with prostate specific
antigen recurrence after surgery
in a study on the right which is in 2020
this is titled the interrogation of
dysregulated Pathways enables Precision
medicine and mental cell lymphoma what
they did was that they conducted
molecular profile analysis on clinical
patient samples and identified Hallmarks
such as the average apoptosis and e2f
Targets in the patient samples so from
this study they identified three
enriched Pathways in relapse mantle cell
lymphoma from the Hallmarks that they
analyzed and so the takeaway from the
increasing interest is that changes in
the Hallmarks are thought to provide
interest Insight in terms of patient
response
so in our study we assess whether or not
uhr replicates would be an appropriate
reference distribution the uhrs again
are composed of various cancer cell
lines and so the gene sets genes
associated with the uhrs were filtered
by the prioritized 27 Gene sets for
breast cancer
we also had the identified patient data
and these are paired we had pre and on
treatment
and in addition of the 42 ER uhr
replicates there are two different laws
based upon sequencing dates so from the
42 we went down to 38 uhr samples based
on the sequencing dates Lot 1 was
sequencing conducted after November 9
2019 Lot 2 was sequencing conducted
before August 22nd 2018 and for both of
these Lots one large fragmentation batch
was prepared and then lot one the batch
has been used for all subsequent
sequencing runs
it
so now we can take a look at the average
expression of the data before filtering
and so as we can see here the y-axis
represents the logged average expression
the x-axis is labeled out by the number
of uhrs we had and then they're labeled
out by what lot they came from so we had
38 uhrs and so looking at this we can
see that the medians for the box plots
are relatively similar however the most
concerning part about this box plot is
how long the tailors are and how much
variability that these Tails indicate
and so because of this variability we
wanted to look towards filtering in
order to tackle this variability
so then that leads us into our workflow
so first we would evaluate gene
expression and compare filterings so we
had two filtering methods more one is
more stringent the other one is less
stringent then we would compute
differences in gene expressions for the
uhr distribution so differences in gene
Expressions we called them deltas and
then the differences would be the
absolute value of the differences then
we computed the differences in gene
expressions for the patient distribution
and so the patient distribution would be
used as a comparison point for our uhr
distribution then we would compare the
uhr distribution with the patient
distribution and as we hypothesize the
uhr expression should be representative
of the patient samples then lastly we
would evaluate the uhr as a null
reference distribution so basically an
assessment of whether or not the uhr
distribution meets the key
characteristics for an optimal reference
or null distribution in addition we want
to see if we can generalize this with
other cancers not just breast cancer
so now we're looking at the move towards
filtering as we saw in the unfiltered
boss plots we saw long tails indicating
High variability and when comparing it
with this patient box plot here we can
see that the patients have shorter tails
in terms of this area right here and so
this indicates that the uhr distribution
had more variability than the patient
distribution and so this patient
distribution again was the two
de-identified patient samples with pre
and on therapy values and what's
interesting here is that when we're
looking at the median the uhr
distribution had a median of 3.1 whereas
the patient distribution had a median of
8.9
and so since we saw variability between
loss for the uhr distribution and in
addition higher variability when Lot 1
and Lot 2 were combined for separate we
also saw a large distribution of low
expressing genes and then from this we
had two sets of cutoff metrics which
again the first one is more stringent
and then the less the second one is less
stringent
so going further in depth with our
cutoff metrics for set one and set two
we start out with 42 ehrs and the reason
why 42 goes down to 38 is because again
the sequencing dates that we were
interested in looking at both of the
sets started out with 60 000 genes
however set one went down to 533 genes
being a more stringent filtering
criteria and then set two went from 60
000 to 10 000 being less stringent then
the first set of cutoff metrics and so
for lot one we had 26 uhrs giving us 325
pairwise style tests for a given Gene
and it's basically 26 choose two and
then similarly with Lot 2 and then the
overall okay wise deltas
so now we can take a look at the average
expression values for the first set of
cutoff metrics and as we can see the
tails are a lot shorter but there's
still variability within this area here
we can also see that the medians are
relatively similar which which is what
we saw before filtering and so with this
first set of cutoff metrics we went from
60 000 to 533 so we have fewer genes but
the overall expression is higher and we
had more modest Deltas with this cutoff
metric
we can also look at the second set of
cutoff metrics so we went from sixty
thousand to ten thousand so more genes
but then we have lower expression and
higher variability as indicated by these
Tails here
so the evaluation of utilizing ranks so
we have Deltas which is just differences
based upon gene expression these were
two variables because we saw batch
effects between the lot so lot one and
lot two and then we also had scaling
issues and then we moved on to using
rank Deltas so this would be determining
ranks based on gene expression the
highest gene expression would receive a
rank of one second highest would receive
a rank of two and so then we would take
the differences based upon the ranks and
so this would tackle the issue of the
scaling
so the key question that we wanted to
answer with the ranked Deltas was that
are the genes with no oral expression in
the uhrs affecting the distribution of
the ranks so first we filtered the genes
to select the genes that were associated
with 27 Gene sets that represented the
Hallmarks and so our filtering
thresholds for the uhrs there's four of
them one is keeping genes with zero
expression two is removing genes with
zero expression three is keeping genes
with greater than one average expression
and four is keeping genes with greater
than 10 average expression
so as for our methods for the uhr
distribution we remove genes based on
the filtering evaluation so those were
the four filtering thresholds that we
saw on the previous slide we then
extracted the genes associated with each
of the 27 genes sets that were
associated with the Hallmarks so from
there we had 24 7 27 data frames that we
were working with and we also had a
patient comparator which is the 2D
identified patient samples both with
biopsy one so pre-treatment and then by
obviously two being on treatment from
there we computed the ranks so a higher
gene expression would be a lower ranked
number then we computed the ranked
Deltas by taking the absolute value of
the differences and for the uhrs it
would be the difference in rank between
all the pairs for the patient data it
would be biopsy 1 minus biopsy two
taking the absolute value of that from
there we would compare the uhr bank
Deltas with the ranked Deltas for the
two patient samples
now we can take a look at the impact of
filtering on the Hallmarks so this First
Column here indicates the 27 Gene sets
that were prioritized by KDL these next
four columns indicates the filtering
thresholds that we looked at and then
the one that we want to focus on is
keeping genes with greater than 10
average depression because we want to
filter out the low expressing genes and
so this pathway right here crash
signaling down regulated had over 93 of
the genes lost when we're looking at
keeping genes with greater than 10
average expression
and we can look at this even further
where there were five pathways with
greater than 70 of the genes lost and
then only two Pathways were less than 20
percent of the genes lost
so one of the pathways I'd like to look
at is I'll six stat three signaling
so one of the questions we had was our
little expression genes in the uhrs also
low expressing in the patient's samples
because the whole idea is that we want
our uhr reference distribution to be
well representative of the patient
distribution
and so we're seeing that this isn't the
case because the low expressing genes
and the uhrs are both High expressing
and low expressing in the patient data
meaning that they're not well
representative of the patient
distribution and there's also
variability in how these genes are being
expressed in the patient distribution
and similarly we can look at this in
terms of ranks because High expression
genes would receive a small rank value
whereas low expression Gene low
expressing genes would receive a large
rank value so there's variability in how
the ranks are too
so as an overall our main question with
this aim to was to determine if the uhrs
would give us an appropriate reference
distribution so as we saw a number of
the Hallmarks would not be able to be
evaluated given the percentage of genes
missings if the uhrs are the reference
normal tolerated missingness is 20 but
we had Pathways were greater than 70 of
the genes were lost
and secondly of those who are low
expressing in the uhrs we don't see them
as consistently though expressing the
patients because again the low
expression in uhrs were both low
expressing and high expressing in the
patients
and additionally we need to consider
that some genes will be variable due to
the disease status of the patient not
just looking at uhr versus primary
sample tissue but patient specific
considerations
in addition the uhrs also appear to
inflate patient outliers if low
expression is not accounted for
and since we've been looking at this in
the context of breast cancer we can look
at this in assessing other disease types
as well so again taking the same pathway
our six stat three singling we took
these genes we imported it into gtex and
the gtex project is samples collected
from 54 on disease tissue sites from
about a thousand individuals and as we
can see from this when we're reading
this plot the yellow indicates that
these are low expressing the blue the
more intense the blue gets that means
that the genes are highly expressing and
so overall we can see that the uhr
distribution may not be expressing the
relevant genes and so if we can see this
lime green section here this is lung we
can see that if the UE chars were to be
used as a reference distribution for
lung it would underestimate the majority
of the genes and so almost all the
patients would be seen as overexpressed
for this given pathway
and so going back to the key
characteristic characteristics that we
defined for an optimal null reference or
optimal reference or null distribution
we stated that the expression samples
should be appropriate for the disease
type and as we saw this isn't the case
because the UE Char has had a lot of low
expressing genes so that means we would
have a loss of the Hallmarks and these
aren't representative of other types so
for instance like the lung example that
we just looked at
the second characteristics that we
stated was that there's biological
variability sample sample but isn't due
to technical artifacts this also isn't
met because we had batch effects lot one
compared to Lot 2 and lot two lot one
and lot two combined were variable
in addition we said that there should be
a large enough distribution to avoid
sampling error
and so this isn't met as well because of
batch effects and then there's also
issues of sampling genes dependent on
the gene filtering criteria
and then the fourth characteristic that
we stated was that hair wise differences
among samples should reflect normal
biological variability but be less than
the actual treatment effects if there
are any present and this would allow us
to identify real changes on therapy this
also hasn't met because we had batch
effects and then low expressing and the
reference distribution led to artificial
inflation of patient metrics
and so as an overall summary in AIM one
we looked at the evolution of testing
targeting the question of how has
Laboratory Testing evolved then we
looked at the increasing complexity and
Laboratory Testing how do we address the
gaps in pipeline development and in AIM
two we trans we transition into looking
at an increased emphasis on rigor and
appropriateness so essentially how do we
validate models how do we evaluate the
approprieness of said validation then we
saw that there was an increased interest
in a null reference distribution and
from there the null Refuge distribution
would give us a baseline point to
determine if there was a real treatment
effect
and then lastly we looked at the
increasing need for validation how do we
best evaluate the methods and as an
overall conclusion to effectively
transition from research to clinical
usage there is a great need for the
validation and hardening of complex and
heterogeneous algorithms
thank you so much for your time and I'll
be happy to take any questions now
thank you a very interesting talk
um are there any questions from the
audience you can either unmute yourself
or type them into the chat
I mean I mean actually I can make a
comment and and it has little to do with
your work which is
um outside my area but um as we see all
these uh and actually maybe it is a
potential angle as we see you know all
of the um kind of um um
AI models and and I guess some of which
apply to Clinical Laboratory tests but
you know also apply to other kinds of
data
um wondering whether we need some
similar kind of regulation in AI I'm I'm
hearing comments on it I'm not really
asking you a question but I'm just the
thought pops into my mind
she kind of um touched on that but I
think Bill you're exactly right we're
seeing that with the FDA right they're
reconsidering the regulation now right
so it's very Timely
good well okay if there are no um
questions from the public
um we we can um dismiss everyone
including myself and um leave Angie with
her uh committee and they'll take it
from there
so thank you everyone for attending
thank you